it's review time review time
[Music]
so nurips has recently released
the reviews for submitted papers and
pretty much everyone is not happy and i
think
the reason is that even though you have
the
reasonable reviewers of these
conferences there is always
always reviewer number two and reviewer
number two
leaves very short review says that
either there are not enough experiments
or the theory is too weak
or the assumptions aren't warranted or
they just don't like your
face and that's why they give you a weak
reject
actually some of them think your paper
is fantastic and give you a weak reject
so a lot of people
are angry upset dissatisfied
with the quality of the reviews in
machine learning conferences
and today i want to go look a bit into
how
this works why this is the way that it
is
and what we could potentially do about
it so what's happening with publishing
in
ml the system seems to be overloaded
there's so much attention
in machine learning right now that there
hasn't been
a few years ago that there's a huge
influx of new people
wanting to publish in this field that
creates a lot of submissions
and not enough reviewers to peer review
these submissions
so a lot of reviewers are recruited that
i probably
shouldn't be reviewers i hear stories of
undergrads being recruited as
reviewers people from way outside the
fields
people that don't have time so too many
submissions too
few inexperienced and not really expert
reviewers
creates pretty much a random process and
this was also shown
in a few years ago in the then nips
experiment
where it showed that for most papers
being accepted is pretty much
a coin flip with a weighted coin the
natural response as an author is going
to be you're going to submit even more
papers
if it's a coin flip you can just submit
whatever and
there's a chance it might get in which
of course only makes the problem
worse so this entire process of science
where you submit your manuscript and
then you get the reviews and then you
try to improve it
it's completely broken because not only
do you not care about the reviews
the next set of reviewers at the next
conference are going to be different
so no matter what you improve right now
the next set of people will have
completely different
criticism it just doesn't work like it
is intended
to work the review process is basically
just some kind of a
random nuisance to people that they have
to
get through and at the same time people
who are reviewers have
every incentive to make it as hard as
possible for the people
that are submitting so in order to
analyze this
i want to look at the incentives of the
different groups
in this process and kind of show how the
incentive structure
upholds this system that benefits pretty
much
everyone participating in it but creates
a worse outcome
for all of us so first of all let's look
at paper authors
what are your incentive if you're an
author of a paper
first of all authors they want to get as
many papers as possible
as fast as possible now in the current
conference
system the fastness isn't really up for
debate it's as
fast as it is however authors can simply
upload their paper
to archive and be as fast as they want
there
another incentive for authors is to have
as little comments on your paper as
possible
because comments usually mean criticism
and you don't want comments and
especially you don't want
public permanent comments the good thing
for authors right now is
on archive comments aren't possible and
conference reviews even if they're made
public
no one goes to look at them everyone
just goes to archive
so authors right now are getting a
pretty good deal with respect to not
getting their work
criticized authors are also incentivized
to give as
little credit to people as possible and
again the current system is totally in
favor of that the no commenting on
archive basically
means that you can claim whatever you
want and if someone wants to refute you
they have to
make a big deal out of it and basically
write their own paper
and again people will probably not find
that
on the other hand in the conferences
reviewers are supposed to detect when
you're not giving proper credit to other
people
however most reviewers don't do that
going out
and really looking if everything is
credited properly
is one of the most time consuming tasks
when you review a paper
and most reviewers simply aren't going
through
that trouble the only downside for most
authors is
even though all of this is pretty much
in their favor
a lot of them still require that stamp
of approval
that peer review accepted at a good
conference so their incentive is to keep
submitting to conferences as many papers
as possible basically count on that
random process
to get them accepted and after that
they're just
fine they have the stamp of approval
there's absolutely no requirement to
revise it
have other people comment
further on the work so i guess the
complaining here
right now is just about the noisy
process and everyone complains that
their particular paper which is at the
behest of the noisy process as everyone
else's paper
got an unfair treatment in that random
process which
half the papers do probably more the
incentives in the systems are actually
even bigger
for what i call the big names okay these
are the big research institutions of
companies
or big name professors anyone that has
some sort of reputation
people argue that anonymous reviewing is
actually
good for small authors good for unknown
authors because it hides their identity
and the big names
basically aren't able to play their big
name credit to a paper however there's
an easy way to know
that this isn't the case the big names
are doing just
fine here's the issue if you want your
name to be attached to something
you're gonna find a way to do it people
are suggesting archive blackout periods
and whatnot anonymous submissions to
archive
you have to realize that if someone
wants
to give some information to the public
they are going to
in fact right now the big names are
finding every possible way
to have their names attached to things
and massively increase their chances of
getting through the
anonymous peer review process you gotta
realize if you're well connected not
only do you have an advertising platform
but you can also pretty easily find out
who your area chairs are
who's reviewing um in which track your
paper gets and so on so allow me to
be a little bit skeptical about the
claim that we need more anonymity
in this process i think we need less
second
what are the incentives of the
conferences itself so the conference
organizers they want to have a good
reputation which basically means they
want to be like a
cool night club lots of people want to
get in
but they have to reject a lot of those
people in order to make the club
exclusive and have a high reputation so
conferences have every reason to invite
everyone to submit as much as possible
but then to reject as much as possible
to make it seem like it's super hard to
get in this only makes the problem
worse and i think the current explosion
isn't really desired by the conferences
as the process is super noisy they're
slowly losing their reputation
that way but still the incentives aren't
to
lower the amount of submissions and
increase the overall
quality because that means a higher
percentage of submissions will have to
get accepted
which means that the conference appears
to be less exclusive and lastly
let's look at the reviewers themselves
this is the most screwed up part in the
system
i have every incentive to be a reviewer
for one of these conferences because
i can write that on my cv hey i was a
reviewer at big name conference
and then once i am accepted as a
reviewer i have every incentive to do
absolutely nothing in fact
the less time i waste with this the
better
because i'm not getting any public
credit i'm anonymous right
anonymous peer review i'm not getting
any reputation out of this
and in fact i can only lose from
accepting papers
and i can only lose from writing
detailed
reviews if i'm short and vague and i
reject a paper not only can i
not really be criticized because i'm not
saying much
it's actually in my overwhelming
interest if the paper
has some sort of big mistake and i
overlook it and i accept the paper
and the other reviewers see that mistake
this looks really really bad for me
even though i'm anonymous in the broader
context it also looks bad for the area
chair supervising me if they don't see
it
it looks bad for the conference if their
area chairs don't see it
so there's a massive push to not
make mistakes however if i reject a
paper that was
actually good i can just say well they
can resubmit to the next
conference so i already have a giant
prior to reject a paper
add to that that usually the papers that
i review
might be my competition and by the
conference incentive of being pretty
exclusive
the more of my competition gets accepted
the less
i might get accepted because not only
are there
limited amount of space not formally but
informally
other work might overlap substantially
with my own and therefore make it less
likely that i get published
also other work might actually criticize
my work
and i don't like that and this is a bit
cynical but
i'm not saying everyone does this but
there is an incentive
for you as a reviewer especially if the
work is close to what you're doing
to reject it now implement the same or a
very similar idea
and then submit to the next conference
where these other authors also will
submit
and hope for the random process to just
for your paper to get more lucky than
their paper black planting on
archive counters this a little bit but
i'm afraid that
with proposed solutions like more
archive blackout periods more anonymity
these problems will only get worse maybe
some people don't realize this but as a
reviewer it's
really easy for me to reject a paper
i can almost always find reasons to
reject a paper if it's a theory paper
i can ask for experiments if it's an
experimental paper
i can ask for more experiments why
didn't you test that data set
why didn't you compare against this
method why are your assumptions so
strong they're never
guaranteed in practice is the problem
even relevant your theory is
too weak have you looked at this other
special case
and if i really want to i can just ask
many
many many questions not even criticisms
just many
questions and i know the authors just
have a one-page rebuttal
they can never answer all my questions
if i do that and then i can simply argue
the authors failed to address
all my questions properly so you might
be asking
why do some reviewers actually do a good
job
and that is i believe really a lot to do
with good will most people are actually
well intended most people actually want
to do a good job
in reviewing have the ethos of science
and
do take the time to do the reviews even
though they're incentivized
to do them badly even though they're
incentivized to reject
papers a lot of people still do a good
job however
reviewer number two usually doesn't and
it only needs a very few reviewer number
twos
to make the field a whole lot worse now
there's a question to be said
aren't we all a bit reviewer number two
have you ever written a review
that the authors might think is
completely unreasonable
and while there is some truth to that
argument i
definitely know that there are
differences in reviews in fact i've
heard people
brag about writing two line reviews
where the second line is you didn't cite
and compare to my own work
and then laugh about that so goodwill
won't carry us all the way
if the incentive structure is bad and i
believe most of this
is because we've taken out the
reputation game
out of the review process in smaller
fields of science it used to be that the
journal editors
knew the reviewers and their reputation
at least towards the journal editor
was on the line for all of future
if they did a bad job right now
everything's so big so anonymous
people hardly remember the names of
their co-reviewers
no reputation is being damaged by bad
reviews and that's how we get here
so of course i'm not the first one to
observe these problems
so many people have proposed solutions
and most of these solutions fall into
the basis of what i would call
ac based methods which is basically
where
someone evaluates the reviews while the
reviews
remain anonymous and that someone is
usually the
area chair so right now the area chair
can already decide that a
reviewer is really bad and then the
reviewer will not be invited to review
the next time around i just want to
point out the irony of the situation
conferences nowadays have so little
reviewers that they
require every author to be a reviewer
but then your punishment for writing bad
reviews
is that you won't be invited to be a
reviewer the next time around i mean can
you make
a better point that the system is
failing
of course the problem with all ac based
methods is that you're basically
moving a problem that has everything to
do
with people being unaccountable noisy
not experty having no time and every
single incentive to do as little as
possible
you transfer that problem to even less
people
that have even less time that have even
more stress that have an even broader
view and topic area and are
single people instead of three or four
people
so it's even more noisy if anything like
this is implemented
you'll just instead of seeing complaints
about bad reviews
in addition you will also see complaints
about bad
acs that will certainly not make the
problem any less in fact
i would argue any ac based solution will
make the problem
worse other solutions are what i call
payment based solutions
like give the reviewers money to review
i don't see how that fixes the incentive
for you to reject anything
you just might write it in a little bit
more eloquent style also as soon as you
bring
money into the game that automatically
excludes a lot of people depending on
how you do it
that aren't as affluent which is
certainly something we don't want as a
community
other people are pointing to things like
open review which
i agree is a better system however
it is still anonymous so the same
incentives exist
and it is still a conference where you
get a
stamp of accept or reject
and once it's accepted no one cares
about the reviews anymore in fact
in open review you can write as much
text as you want so the acs are even
more overloaded
with lots of text to make their
decisions so something i want to
highlight is a thread by thomas g
dietrich on twitter where he basically
suggests some sort of a
wiki and sort of a collaborative
research wiki
where you'd have a set of senior authors
that
basically maintain that wiki that do a
first
check of papers and kind of
match them against the wiki of what's
already known i
won't go through that here i will link
it and i definitely advise you to read
it because it's very interesting
proposal it's a sort of utopian
dream i would actually welcome if we all
work together on increasing the
knowledge of mankind
in a wiki style way however i think lots
of people
want their names attached to things and
even if you do
what thomas suggests and basically have
people write papers and then the editors
integrate that into the wiki it is
not clear how that system where the
editors clearly need to be senior and
experienced
could deal any better with the explosion
of research
that we're dealing right now they would
be as overloaded as the current system
plus who's gonna be an editor thomas
says becoming an editor would be a very
esteemed career path
and again i completely welcome
if that were the case in the future
however simply decreeing that something
would be
very esteemed doesn't make it that way
it's not
fiat money so as much as i would like
that i just don't believe it would work
and especially i don't believe
it would work right now and i think it
would be subject to the
same problems so can we come up with a
better
solution i think yes but the way to go
there
is to align what we want as a community
with the incentives of people and not go
against it because as soon as you go
against it too much
people will find a way around it so the
first thing i want to suggest
is we abolish conference publishing
this weird notion that you submit
your paper to this conference and then
all at the same time
a random process is happening and three
random people give their opinion while
reading your paper
for a couple of minutes and then you get
an accept after which your paper is
there
never to be revised or a reject which
simply means you try again
seems to be preposterous i'm sorry so
people wonder yep
how do we know when a paper is accepted
who cares about acceptance
who cares why can't we just switch to
citations citations is a pretty good
measure of
how much people care about a paper and
yes big names will get more citations
but they do so now and they do so more
effectively
than ever why can't we just put our
papers on archive
and then run some kind of pagerank
algorithm over the
citations such that self citations
aren't worth as much i mean
search engines figured out how to
deliver
you the most relevant search result to a
query
20 years ago why can't we simply apply
the same techniques
to research determining this work is
quite relevant
this work is not that quite relevant i
get it citations
take time and you won't immediately know
after publishing
but i think that's a step we can take
especially since conference publishing
is also lagging like half a year behind
publishing on archive during which
pretty much nothing happens and then
people say oh but what about
peer review peer review peer review does
not work peer review is a
joke in machine learning okay no one
cares about the reviews reviewers are a
nuisance
you have to get past them all the people
still pretend to
care that it means something that
reviewers agree or disagree with you
it doesn't in fact i want to get to a
system where peer review
starts at the moment where you publish a
paper on something like
archive and then never finishes for the
lifetime
of that paper as new knowledge comes in
from the field the paper can be
continuously re-examined and if the
paper turns out to be
really important more and more scrutiny
can be applied to it seems like a much
better system
than simply throwing the same amount of
pretty random reviewers at every paper
and then giving it the
stamp or not so here's what i suggest we
keep something like
archive but amend it with a commenting
function
and the commenting can be pretty feature
rich so you could
incorporate plots and references to
other things
this goes very much towards a kind of a
collaboratively edited wiki
but where people still put their names
on things
so let's say i publish a paper someone
else could publish a comment which would
be
not less in quality than a paper it can
be it can be a two line comment
it can be a full rewrite of the paper
it can be an amendment so i could have
published a paper and someone else could
say
look i've done your code on a different
data set and here are the
results people could then cite my paper
or they could cite comments
and the citations will determine the
relevance
the comments would also be right there
on archive so every time someone goes to
look at that paper
they'll see the comments along with it
so if the paper has a big mistake
they'll basically see the comment that
says
hey this paper has a mistake and i can
prove it right here and then they can
maybe see a response to that saying
no you're wrong and people can make up
their own minds we could build in some
kind of voting system like a stack
overflow system
for ranking comments but instead of
making this stamp of approval thing a
one-time event by a random set of people
let everyone make up their own mind and
let people discuss
and you can even have anonymous comments
on these sites because the comments will
be evaluated
on what they are writing and not who it
is
by now of course if it does turn out
that commenting will become
cool after a while you can also comment
non anonymously
and maybe get little medals like you get
on stack overflow i don't see that
happening
but if it does the better now as a side
suggestions can we please
stop publishing stuff in pdfs it's
so like why do we still do this
this many pages this margin and so on i
get it some people still print out their
papers
but websites are so much nicer to
look at and can be made to print
adequately
let's start publishing research as html
not as pdfs so remember when i said the
authors have a big incentive to
not have comments on their paper this
pretty much goes against that right so
it is
entirely conceivable that the authors
will just start
self-hosting big company like google
could simply not
publish to archive anymore they could
simply publish to
their own website and remove themselves
from the ability for other people to
comment now this can be solved
technologically pretty easy by
creating something like a browser plugin
that
if you find a piece of research anywhere
it'll simply
fuzzy match the title find the
appropriate comments to that research
as a unified set of comments across all
of the
internet in contrast conferences should
be
conferences it should be places where
people come up
meet up and talk about relevant issues
that are happening
right now if i go to a conference now
most of the talks on the papers is from
research that is six months old or older
why don't we have conferences
that are simply consisting of invited
keynotes panel discussions and
things that are now called workshops
where we discuss current maybe
unfinished research have poster sessions
for many more people there's no
acceptance there's no
declining if there's not enough room do
a lottery or something like this
but make the conferences a place where
science is happening
and not where we flash six months old
research
so why is this not happening i already
said that most of the incentives are
actually
towards the current system as much as
people complain about it now conferences
are slowly losing
their reputations as i said because
over time people will catch on to the
fact that the signal
being accepted at particular conferences
is more and more
noisy however the system is still upheld
by most
phd students for example needing a
certain amount of conference accepted
submissions
in order to graduate so what we really
need
is professors and i'm calling on every
professor out there
to start giving out phds
while absolutely not caring about the
number
of conference accepted submissions that
a student
has and that seems like something that's
very doable because it requires
individuals
professors to simply change their
practices with which
they let people graduate so that was it
for my little rant on conferences and
reviewer number two
please let me know what you think in the
comments
i value your input very much and i hope
we can get to a future
where conferences are conferences and
research is just done on the basis of
its coolness and relevance
all right i'll see you bye
you